[Music]
okay so i guess my secret is that i'm
mildly afraid of pregnant people
just the idea of like having a whole
entire human just like incubating inside
of you until it's ready to pop and claw
its way out of your body is just a
little terrifying but
child life and birth is beautiful or all
that jazz
[Music]
so when i was younger i lost someone
very close and very important to me and
since then i try to do everything i can
for others
to be with them to support them
and sometimes it comes off as a lot but
i really try my best to make everyone
feel as close and as welcome as possible
and
doesn't always come off in the most
calm way but
i really hope people know that
i'm always rooting for them whether
we're super close or
we just met
even in my 50s i'm still searching for
tim who i dated in my 20s i believe he
was who i was supposed to marry but i
did not
[Music]
my secret is i've been in a relationship
for 10 years married for eight
have two children
and i want my own house without my
[Music]
husband so i was visiting my friends for
the weekend and i was driving it was
late at night it was dark rainy and i
was crossing this four-way stop
and there's people that were also going
across the street but they went
basically behind the car that i was
approaching and not on the crosswalk so
i'm driving passing forward and all of a
sudden these people come from the
underside of the truck that i'm going
past and
i hit this girl with my car and she
rolls up on my hood and then tumbles
down and hits the ground and i was like
oh my gosh are you okay and her friends
are like what the [ __ ] are you so
serious like why did you do that like
blah blah and i was like is she okay and
like she's fine she's fine and they
walked away into the night with nothing
ever happening no cops called no serious
injuries i thought i was done for i had
to tell thought i was gonna have to tell
my dad and i was just it was the most
perfect situation to hit a person so
that's my secret
[Music]
i guess my secret would be that i'm
always trying to be
a better version of myself but i'm never
always meeting that expectation i guess
it's i'm always comparing myself to
others and trying to meet their
expectations but it never really
correlates for me so i guess that's one
of my flaws
[Music]
one time i was at my grandmother's house
and she made me and my cousin like 30
chicken nuggets and she only fed us six
because she wants us to keep our girlish
figure and then i started going to
therapy
i'm really freaked out by twins
they just it's freaks me out way too
much
[Music]
when i was younger and when it would
rain i would drink the puddle of water
on the ground because i was too lazy to
go to the waterhole
i told my teacher i was going through
something
i wasn't going through nothing i just
wanted to pass the test
i secretly like the taste of baby food
and sometimes pack it in my lunch
[Music]
i collect and carry ketchup packets in
my purse
[Music]
i still watch minecraft videos like when
i was 12 years old
it was the fifth grade
i was at my friend's house
we were in his room
we were we were lying on the floor
drawing in our sketchbooks
when i feel like i felt like i needed to
go to the bathroom
so i got up
i went into the bathroom
and it was diarrhea
it was terrible terrible diarrhea
i look at the
the thing where you put the toilet paper
there's nothing on there
i look inside the little cupboard under
the sink there's nothing in there i'm
torn and i don't know what to do
so i look at my socks that are on my
feet
i take them off
and that's what i have to use
i'm standing there
with [ __ ] covered socks in my hands
not knowing what to do
so i put them in my pockets that i walk
out
[Music]
so when i began my search for work i
didn't have a place to live and ended up
couch surfing quite a lot
and i would go to meet-ups in the
industry by going online to try to find
out where some great places where people
can network and connect i didn't have a
job at the time but i didn't want people
to know that i didn't have a job so at
one point during our
meetups and networking events i received
a business card
and so i ended up getting taking this
business card heading to fedex kinkos
and taking this business card
changing the name and phone number and
email address to my own
and then i would go to future networking
events with this business card with
adjusted to say my name
and that's how i was able to make my way
into more meetups and eventually into a
part-time job that turned into a
full-time job so
um it was kind of a secret that i took
someone else's business card to
adjust it for my own name
but in the end it helped me start my
career
that's my story
my secret is
that i secretly wish that me and my best
friend wouldn't have gotten to it and
that we could be in our relationship but
i know it's not to happen so i'm just
better with knowing the things that i
know and knowing that her and her family
is okay
[Music]
all right i feel like a secret that i
have is that most of my some of my close
friends like i would consider close
they don't
respect me enough nor do i feel like
they put enough energy or effort
that i would show to them in a sense but
i don't know i feel like it's kind of
hard and i don't want to confront them
because they're really close to me but
i don't know what i should do
[Music]
who holds the secret
we do
i do
and in knowing this
i have chosen to heal
with you
gifted this opportunity just thinking
about my secrets
and knowing that i have been revealing
some secrets to individuals that i felt
was very very important to me
and one of those individuals that i just
felt i want to make sure you always are
protected any way i could
and doing that
i had
to let a secret be known to my 18 year
old son
and
that secret was the why
why
do you feel a need to not
connect with your dad
in such a way that is harmonious
as we would want it to be
as i thought about it
i felt a need to tell my son the secret
because i want to make sure i was being
fair to him
like i would have loved for generations
of
many times others being fair
to me as a child so as his mom i let him
receive something that was so heavy on
me for years but with the focus of
protecting him
so
i would keep him away from his granddad
in a way because i said well i want to
make sure that i guide this relationship
in a way that i feel that when he become
an adult he can handle himself but as a
child i want him to know that my dealing
with
granddad
can be very
uncomfortable and that uncomfortableness
started at the age of 19 and here i am
at 44 just letting my son know at 18
the secret
i know that when it comes to mental
health
it can be very overwhelming and that's
the reason why i share with you all
lovingly
that secret that i am now expressing
healing in this present moment because
when it comes to the choice
i have chosen to heal in all areas of my
life as best as i can
i was in a scenario where my dad truth
he had just experienced being
incarcerated for
i think that was like 10 years of my
life yes because i was nine and he's
coming home newly i'm happy because my
dad knew about something that occurred
when i was 17 when my mom just passed i
experienced a rape
and so in that my dad was that i would
have protected you so i'm trusting my
dad and sharing information with him
because i want to be stronger when it
comes to being the creator that i am be
comfortable with myself so when my dad
come i'm like trusting that we're
drinking and then that trusted him
examined his own child's body he touched
it i withdrew and i stopped him and i'm
very grateful that i was able to but
then i also took on
trust you trust and look what happened
so in sharing that with my son and i
share this with you all the gratitude of
knowing that my why
it's an honor to be present as i am
because i know that mental healing
is something that i'm gifted because i
choose to accept it so as i continue to
heal
i am honored
to share this secret
which is now my healing and i will
continue to accept my healing
because it is a gift to the world
[Music]
hey everyone for those of you who are
new my name is thoria and i'm the girl
behind the camera i actually plan on
taking the series to new city every
month starting with today's episode you
probably noticed it was filmed in
chicago and next month it's going to be
new york so stay tuned for that make
sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you'll be notified
every time i have a new episode up and
follow me on instagram i'll be posting
more on there as i'm traveling so
that'll be fun
as always thank you guys for everything
i love you all and i'll see you next
time